également sur les écrans mercredi la
machine c'est suffisamment rare pour
être signalé les producteurs français
ont résisté aux sirènes américaine en
confiant à un français françois dupeyron
la réalisation de ce film fantastique à
suspense dans lequel s'illustrent gérard
depardieu en médecins démoniaque
pascal deschamps et claude barnier l'ont
rencontré
il en est fier de sa machine au bon
docteur lacroix car il doit permettre à
ce psychiatre de renom de firmes une
expérience unique entrée dans les
pensées d'un de ses patients un tueur
psychopathe pour les comprendre enfin
une expérience pour le bien de
l'humanité mais mais quand ça se
détraque alors là on peut on peut
commencer à faire un film ou avoir peur
et pour ce détraqué elle se détraque la
machine car c'est un véritable transfert
de personnalité qui s'opèrent chacun se
retrouvant dans le corps de l'autre
gérer placement
vous a compris maintenant alors appuyé
tout va revenir dans l'ordre appuyées il
n'appuie rapport troupe heureux de la
chance qui lui est offerte de changer de
vie douce quand tu sociale des familles
qui a fait quoi cela c'est bien lui qui
a poignardé des rentes déjà
parquet
ça va
ce qui me plaît
je veux pas dire de lui que c'est un
criminel parce qu'il n'a pas de suite eu
comprendre il a pas de fait c'est pas
lui moi je regrette un peu qu'il y ait
plus de films comme cela comme y avait
dans ims coque où on avait vraiment peur
je me souviens qu'il y avait un fils qui
avait fait peur vraiment 1% l'ehpad
extraordinaire commandes il n'y avait
pas de sang ni deux il y avait une
menace
c'était dans la nuit du chasseur de
charles laughton voilà il avait cette
menace comme ça sur des enfants et
maintenant on a voulu on serait plus
dans la science fiction
je ne vous imaginez pas en train effet
les courses je vous voyais
le tout au milieu de vos malades
un arceau des malades tenez par exemple
rien qu'ici ya de quoi remplir à cali la
machine réussissons faru ensemble
simplement parce devant nous a pris
corps le pire de nos cauchemars et si ce
qu on m avait changé de fond et si ce
qu'on aime n'étaient pas ceux qu'on
croit